[Applause]
we'd like to present neil baldwin to you
now
neil
[Applause]
thank you can you all hear me back there
i
really appreciate what
lawrence lemur has been saying about
the
responsibility that we have as
authors and and as historians to
to look straight ahead and to be
unsparing in our
conclusions in our research
and i can't think of the number of times
that someone has said to me
over the last five years especially when
i started with the idea of writing a
book
called henry ford in the jews
why do you want to waste your time
this is going down a black hole
we already know all we need to know
etc etc etc
and then the next wave which is as larry
was saying
are you sure that you want to put this
in your book
um are you sure you want to put your
where you live in your you know your
address in your book
are you sure that you want to have a
website
neilbaldwinbooks.com which by the way
you really must visit it's fantastic
um
but in the end and in the end in all
seriousness you have to say to yourself
yes i am sure that i want to do this
um
because why else would you spend well i
guess this was about a five-year
undertaking in addition as you know to
my other my day job
and i think it was well worth it and i
hope that you will also think so
i would just wanted to thank mitchell
kaplan who's the head of this book fair
for inviting me to respond
oh i didn't even know he was here
um
mitchell
it was six years ago my book on thomas
edison came out
and mitchell invited me to his bookstore
books and books
to speak and he also had
as we as the publishing industry calls
it my backlist
book titles in other words the books
that i'd written before the book that
was being published those are called
backlist books
which is a rather unfortunate term but
anyway you had them there man ray and
thomas and william carlos williams and
we signed them and we had a great
evening
so i really appreciate his dedication
to this undertaking
i'm going to just speak for
a short time because i'm sure there are
a lot of questions i know i'd have a lot
of questions if i was in the audience
for this event
i always like to begin my books with a
quote uh epigraph and
i usually
i usually like to begin with several
quotes but i'm just going to read you
the top one
on the epigraph page
to set the tone for this
occasion
if we want to examine the development of
actual belief
as contrasted with social norms
we have to examine
individual lives
for belief is an activity of individuals
ideas or prescriptions are not beliefs
until individuals
assent to them
that's by gavin langmuir and the name of
the book is
history religion and anti-semitism
and the reason i'm reading that to you
is because
i
began
my
non-fiction career as a biographer and
the first three books that i wrote were
definitely
i would say biographies in the classic
mode
they took
the life of one person from beginning to
end
and they
explored their circumstances and their
life story and their family and their
art in the case of
and their writing in the case of
williams and their art the case of man
ray and the technology in the case of
edison
but this book
is really about
is really a biography of an attitude
and that's different
than
taking a person from birth to death
which has a multiplicity of themes you
know you explore their ups and their
downs and their vicissitudes and their
relationships and all of that but in the
case of henry ford
as i was saying to larry before this
we were talking that
i had to
go down a long corridor with many
different doors going off to one side or
the other with lots of very interesting
distracting
themes and
uh
biographical temptations and of course
i'm interested in corporate america i'm
interested in
in ideology i'm interested in history
i'm interested in a lot of different
subjects but i had to go past these
doors and just keep my
my focus on the theme of how
how and why a person of such tremendous
entrepreneurial
fame and fortune could become the most
virulent anti-semite of the 20th century
the first
answer to that question and i don't have
the complete tied up in a bow answer by
the way so i hope you're not going to
wait for that because there isn't any
but the first subtext i had to deal with
was that what was the history of
anti-semitism as a whole
just a just to sort of add to my agenda
so there's a term there's a whole
subtext in the book which is about
the
genesis and existence of anti-semitism
from medieval times
to the present day because i want to
show that ford's behavior
was not an anomaly it was part of a
tradition it was part of a
thousand year long 2000 year long
tradition through many different
cultures and many different
nationalities and many different forms
of belief
the second challenge that i felt i had
to
meet
was to figure out why
ford's propensity to focus on jews
was there one specific incident that
occurred in his childhood
was he you know
was his father
his father take out a loan and never
paid it back or was his farm repossessed
by a jewish landlord or something
cliched or stereotypical like that the
answer to that is no
um i was unable to find any
precipitating incident that
was sort of like the tipping point that
put forth into the into the anti-jewish
camp i found a combination of
circumstances which i just want to
very
schematically
provide to you
he grew up in a
very provincial
small town
outside of detroit
during a pop of the populist era of our
nation a very myopic
point of view in the community
he was schooled on the mcguffey readers
which i talked about in the very first
chapters of my book that's where he
picked up on a lot of the
stereotypical imagery of [ __ ]
and the jew as the
hoarder of money
the jew as the alien the jew as the
outsider
as he became more involved in his
corporate identity running the ford
motor company
and as as we've heard a little bit about
earlier today
um
he came in contact with the
predisposition to blame jews for the
causes of war because the jews were
considered to be the wire pullers behind
the culture behind the culture the
capitalism behind the capitalism
but it wasn't until he was a middle and
fully middle-aged person
that he
this this indoctrination this permeation
with the protestant ethic and with
america as a christian country came to
fruition by which time he had become a
millionaire
and he was completely insulated by his
wealth
he had his own private railroad car
which he used to go wherever he went
he had his of course his fleet of
automobiles and he had a yacht
and
he would sneak around through detroit he
was sort of the invisible man of detroit
he was really in his own little world he
surrounded himself
with a an inner sanctum of
very very
conservative ideological men all of them
were men who wrote
and spoke on his behalf
he never really spoke in a speech for
more than 30 seconds maybe 40 seconds at
the most publicly
his own world view
was uniquely his
and everyone who came into contact with
him
came away with a similar impression
i just want to read you
a very short passage from
a journal that i discovered in the
collections of the new york public
library by a woman named rosica
schwimmer
who i'm sure none of you have heard of
unless of course you've read the book by
now
but
she was a hungarian jewish pacifist
feminist who came over to this country
in
1914 as part of the worldwide feminist
anti-war movement and she got a meeting
with henry ford because she was told
that he too was against
world war one
and against american involvement
and she described him as follows
his strong
ascetic face
reminded me of the portrait of a greek
philosopher i remembered from a rare old
book in my parents library she wrote
and when a humorous twinkle lighted his
face
he looked like a wistful but healthy boy
this combination of sage and boy seemed
to me always apparent in mr ford
and another friend of ford's a
contemporary of his
had the following observation
henry ford has two personalities
one is diffident almost to the point of
bashfulness yet very friendly
in 10 seconds
for no apparent reason
a smile may flip from his face
and you behold a man who from the eyes
up seems as old as the pyramids
back of the boyish board is the ford who
seems to have lived for ages
to have suffered much
and to have survived from the sheer
exercise
of the will to live
once henry ford expressed a point of
view whether it be
to go with a different carburetor in the
car or to publish an anti-semitic
newspaper
or to decide that his his mansion on the
banks of the river rouge river was going
to cost three million dollars and was
going to be built only with limestone
from one particular quarry in indiana
and that was it he was set
and no one could change his mind on
anything
and i think you have to understand that
about his personality to see how he
could develop the motivation to publish
a newspaper called the dearborn
independent the first
91 issues of which
were predominantly devoted to editorial
writings against the jews
in fact the dearborn independent
which henry ford took over it was a
failing country newspaper with a
circulation of several hundred and he
made it into this
uh
dynamic anti-jewish right-wing
publication almost instantly
its main purpose was to promulgate the
protocols of the elders of zion i don't
know how many of you are familiar with
the protocols of the elders of zion but
they are
a forgery which attribute the jewish
motivation to taking over to world
domination essentially and henry ford
was the
first
publisher of the protocols of the elders
of zion in this country and he
serialized them in his newspaper
if you take a look at
at ford's
jew at an anti-jew attitude and try to
put it onto a spectrum which is
something that i also tried to do in my
book
one of the touchstones i used was thomas
edison obviously because i had written a
biography about him which is actually
when i first got the intimation that
this might be a subject i would like to
get involved in
and several people have asked me over
the years
about edison's
anti-semitism and i feel that
they were really on different points of
the spectrum ideologically
let me just share with you a letter that
i found in the thomas edison archives
which are located in west orange new
jersey which is conveniently only about
three miles from where i live so i was
able to do a lot of research over there
during uh on fridays on my day off from
work
and um
there was a whole pile of letters there
that were not sent
or there were drafts of of letters that
were sent
and that immediately attracted my
attention because you can often tell a
lot about you know when someone's
writing a letter to the editor which in
this case is is what we're talking about
and you look at the early drafts you can
see where their mind is going
well what happened was
um jacob schiff who was the chairman of
[ __ ] logan company was a very very
important member of the of the jewish
hierarchy in america
very wealthy philanthropic banker
and he wrote a letter to edison
challenging his uh published attitudes
in the detroit free press and
and and asking him to deny his quote
flighty assertions about jews
and edison drafted a letter in response
elaborating about his theory of of the
jews and what they were and were not
good for and his words
as follows
the jews
are certainly a remarkable people
edison conceded
as strange to me in their isolation
from all the rest of mankind as those
mysterious people called gypsies
well there are some terrible examples in
mercantile pursuits
the moment they get into art music and
science and literature the jew is fine
to edison it was a troubling racial
characteristic
a natural talent for becoming rich
that had caused the meddling jew to be
quote disliked
and here's the part where he changed the
letters is very interesting hopefully
this is me talking hopefully through
continued exposure to modern american
democracy the jew quote
edison in time will cease to be so
clannish
unquote
then the next sentence of the letter
is excised with this very thick black
pencil that edison like to use to mark
things up you know this very black
pencil we pressed really hard the
sentence said i wish they would all stop
making money
and we can look back on this and
sort of
which is you know and i purposely
delivered it as if it were quote funny
unquote which it is kind of in a way
but it also helps helped me to be able
to put forward on us on a spectrum
you know if you compare that kind of um
cliched uh
stereotyped point of view
with having them taking all you know
half a million dollars of your own money
and buying a printing press and printing
you know week after week after week of
screeds against jews and promulgating
them
then i think you you have to come away
thinking seeing that there are there are
levels there are a strata of belief
strata of anti-semitism among these two
who were indeed very close friends
so i guess i differ from
some of the prevailing points of view
which say that edison was what was what
was a major you know sort of impetus for
ford's behavior i disagree
um
let me talk a little bit about so we
have time for questions let me talk a
little bit about my research
uh because i made a very interesting i
think interesting anyway decision about
a quarter of the way into my travels
everybody said
to me oh yeah obviously you're going to
go to dearborn to the fort i guess
you'll be spending most of your time in
dearborn at the ford
uh archives you know i guess that people
would laugh and say gee you know you got
to go to paris for man right now you
have to go to dearborn for the next five
years you know
and and sort of like that but i found
when i went to to the ford museum
i found a rather
disconcerting
paucity shall we say of
information on this subject i guess in
retrospect i shouldn't have been so
naive but um you know i went to the card
file which is all very nicely typed out
there was under the j in the car card
file was jews
comma
opinions of you know like that i started
flipping through the little cards and
had all the different adjectives and
whatever
and uh so would say you know uh c folder
573 or c accession number 573 so i would
fill out the little call slip i asked
for accession number 573 and we come
back as i say this is very thin this
folder is like
i opened it up there would be one piece
of paper in there saying um
removed by the ford motor company
so i said well okay fine i mean they
have their right they have a right to
remove things because they're the ones
that gave all this material to the
non-profit ford museum in the first
place so i filled out another
call slip for accession number 800 and
whatever and that came back and that was
also very thin
and opened that one up and it said
destroyed by the ford motor company
so at that point
i sent an email to the head of the
archives of ford motor company of the
chief archivist and she
wrote back to me very very quickly like
almost
instant messaged me in a way
and she said
all of the information that you need for
your research
i'm sure the staff of the museum will be
very
pleased to help you and which they which
and by the way they were they were
terrific and they did a lot for me but
you can't help a scholar who's looking
for something if it's not there
and was when i read leah iacocca's
memoir
that i found that i began to understand
how
much
henry ford ii
had
gotten rid of
during the
early 60s
early to late 60s
to to thin out the the documentation so
what i decided to do
was go to the jewish archives and you
must say to yourself well that seems
like a pretty obvious thing but i was
amazed
in my travels
american jewish historical society
american jewish committee american
jewish archives jewish theological
seminary i was amazed to discover
the amount of
ferment and the amount of interaction
the amount of discourse that was going
on throughout american jewry of all
levels in all parts of the country
about ford's behavior
the main quandary can be summed up very
easily by
a brief quote from
rabbi henry pereira mendes who was the
head of congregation sheriff israel in
in new york
at the time of this tremendous scandal
he said the following
and this is the big quandary of the
jewish committee the jewish community
excuse me
to answer
feeds the vehemence of the attacks that
is to say ford's attacks
not to answer seems unmanly and gives
the enemies a chance to say our silence
acknowledges our guilt
so there you have the problem which i
try to deal with in the second half of
the book
about how to go up against somebody with
that kind of money and that kind of
public profile and how do you
as a
jewish leader as jacob schiff or lewis
marshall or cyrus adler or whoever the
case may be how do you
speak out without drawing more attention
to yourself
and creating a backlash on the other
hand
if you're quiet
you're rolling over and taking it that's
not good either
so it's through the the riches of the um
the american jewish archives that i
discovered
the um
ways in which the jewish community
was able to try to get together
and respond to ford and of course as
many of you may know in the end it was a
libel suit which caused him to apologize
to the jews in 1927
for his uh
outspoken vehement behavior
now to conclude and of course i can only
touch upon this here
there was a piece in the herald this
morning i believe it was a column
which i
i can't remember the name of the author
was on the left hand side of the page
and it talked about
um
the root causes
of
hate
i think it was dealing with uh there was
an argument in a bowling alley does
anybody remember this column
stein steinbach there was a very very
interesting and
very well
conceived it was about an article about
an argument in a bowling alley and um
the author questions well what if one of
the people were black in the argument
and how would that affect
the the nature of it
and it started me thinking about
how you could ever hope
to penetrate to a level in in writing
about hate
where you can say that you have found
the root cause for an attitude it's kind
of like my
my disclaimer in terms of the book as a
whole
because
as long as i've worked and as deeply as
i've dug especially in these times that
we're living in now
you know you have to ask yourself
how far do you want to pursue
the causationist path whether it be
anti-semitism racism
muslim
afghanistan
tribal you can put any label you want
there in front of it
but i don't see how you can ever be
certain that you've reached the bottom
when you're dealing in some cases with
traditions as i've said that go back
much farther than the lifetimes of the
people you're writing about
which is not to say don't get me wrong
there's no way that henry ford can be
considered a scholar henry ford did not
study
his precedence in history before he came
out with what he came out with
he was operating on his own motivations
and on the formulation of his own
attitudes
and with that i would like to stop since
it seems we have about
seven minutes to go
according to my watch which is of course
new jersey time so i may be wrong
any questions
given the anti-semitism of henry ford
what was the in your view that continued
was there any continuing legacy in the
corporate culture of ford in subsequent
years regarding anti-semitism and jews
and in terms of the
elite of detroit uh as a matter of fact
and that's a very good question which i
talk about in the afterward to the book
um
succeeding generations of ford have been
very
very enlightened and very philanthropic
supporting israel
[Music]
apologizing for the
the misbehavior of their founder
getting involved in the jewish community
and in detroit and dearborn
hiring jews to work in the company
and i think that really
uh
the legacy exists in history obviously i
wrote the book but i'm not the first
to talk about it
however it does not exist in the ford
family anymore
next person in line
two things uh
to just elaborate on what you said about
ford uh hiring jews i know of one jewish
person in in ford who became a
president of ford truck right went on to
become chairman of ford uh asian
operations
and was very high up in the company yeah
what i want to ask you though is
somewhere in back of my mind maybe in my
college days when we study corporations
and and how they came about
something stuck that said
that ford formulated really his
anti-semitism because
i forgot which car
but it was either the model
model a
where he said black was the color that
everybody wanted and competition started
coming out with new cars
and he needed financing
to bring out a new car
and his backers at the time i think were
jewish bankers
they
looked at ford and they said they would
not
give him the money to
bring out the
new car
and he got very angry
about that cursed the jews and said
i will uh get the money i will bring out
the car and i will work and i will go
against you and i
that's something that's stuck in the
back of my mind i wonder if that's true
or not well the jewish bankers again
there's only so many cliches you can
talk about in 40 minutes
as you as you can see i've touched upon
as many cliches as i could but i didn't
get all of them um jewish bankers of
course
uh henry ford accused jp morgan of being
a jewish banker so he had a little bit
of a problem with
with that whole
issue that's true he accused jp morgan
to be a jewish banker uh the the
ford
in uh and this is interesting in light
of the changeover um
which has happened
in the last few weeks and at the company
um
in
the late teens or early 20s
um edsel
and mrs ford clara and henry ford bought
out all the other stockholders
and
assumed 100
ownership of the company
and
throughout
the 80 years since then
the ford there's obviously been a very
active ford presence
in the company and i didn't really under
know until some one told me recently
that they actually get together as
several members of the family or they
all get together occasionally just to
talk about what's going on it's a very
strong
sense of
ownership you know emotion perhaps it's
more emotional but still they have a
predominant voting
authority in the company but there's
always been that that's part of that is
part of the culture
the antipathy to bankers
really predates
the
the issuance of the car and the
promulgation of the car
and that goes back i think to one of the
as i said earlier one of the populist
credos about the rothschilds across the
water and the wire pullers and
the fact that there's really an economy
behind our economy you know the whole
there i also talk in my book at great
length about the founding of the federal
reserve system
in 1910 as you may know paul warburg
was the driving force behind that
he was jewish german jewish
and
ford actually came out at one time and
accused the federal reserve
of being in control by the jews and was
such caused such a furor that there was
a there was a proposed senate hearing
to examine this charge and they asked
for they challenged ford to come and
come up and defend himself
next question
i have one comment before i ask the
question
with respect to fought hiring jews
i know of at least two people
who in the 30s
sought jobs at ford
and in one case one of them
was my brother
changed his last name
in order to hide the fact that he was
jewish to get a job at ford
so
i'm not sure at what period of time
that that approach persisted but my
question concerns
your statement about the
the
litigation
that forced forward to issue an apology
i was
you know i've been aware
most of my life of the fact that
that ford was a vile anti-semite
but i was not aware that there was a
litigation which resulted in in
requiring ford to apologize
could you elaborate on that again and i
have to apologize for being so
perfunctory about some of these things
uh due to the time
constraints that we have and i don't
want to sound
mercenary but you can always buy the
book and read the whole story
but anyway i will just tell you briefly
that
what happened
briefly was
got to a point in the late 20s about
1927 to be precise
after the onslaught of this issue after
issue of this newspaper coming out
ford
initiated a
a series of articles
against
the
incipient farming cooperative movement
farming cooperative movement which was
founded by
a jew
named aaron
sapiro s-a-p-i-r-o
who was from california
and he was kind of yes what you would
call him would be an organizer of the
farmers the first instigation the first
idea that farmers could get together and
they could
produce large quantities pool their
resources bring them to market command
more prices etc and obviously henry ford
was
deeply deeply against such a thing
so he initiated a series of articles
against sapiro
but he took on much more than he had
bargained for and find this was one jew
that
didn't hesitate to speak up because he
was very active actually had studied to
be a rabbi at one time before he decided
to go into law and as a very fascinating
person fascinating person
and
so they brought suit against ford in
detroit
for as i say for libel there was a
blurring effect you know ford's defense
was that he was attacking sapiro as one
person he wasn't attacking all jews
but that didn't last very long that kind
of finessing didn't last very long and
in the end
to avoid a very costly settlement
ford
quote unquote apologized
the apology
was written actually written for him by
louis marshall that president of the
american jewish
committee
who was an attorney
and it was provided to ford through
intermediaries
like a like a mission they went to see
louis marshall lewis marshall wrote this
apology sent it back to ford ford didn't
even read it he told them
put my name on it make it as
bad as you want to make it
say that i'm guilty of everything that i
ever did and more things that i didn't
do and
you know they read it to him over the
phone his people read it to him over the
phone they said are you sure you want to
publish this is going to go out over the
hearst newswire arthur brisbane who was
her right-hand man was gonna put it out
on the wire was gonna be on the front
page of every newspaper in the world
and
ford apologizes end of anti-semitism in
america that was
rather hasty i think with hasty
conclusion um
and uh
in i talk in the book this will have to
be the last
thing but i talk in the book about
i i read some of the interviews with
people who worked for ford during that
time
that survived into the 50s and were
interviewed by these oral historians
from columbia university
and um
he
this one guy um
mr liebold who worked for ford was very
outspoken about the fact that
ford didn't write this
he never read it
he never apologized he said i i he said
i don't think mr ford ever apologized
for anything he might have put his name
on it but we all knew that
mr ford would not apologize for anything
that wasn't in his nature and as a
matter of fact
he went on for another 15 years
right into world war ii
and up until right before he died with
his
uh pronouncements and uh publications
so thank you for your time and
[Applause]
we want to thank you all for coming to
hear these two wonderful authors um have
a good day and thanks for being here
bye-bye
[Music]
but
dr levine and bernardo bennis will be
speaking
the lecture has been moved to chapman
and directly